the founders of Airbnb did one of the
wildest Things I've ever heard of to
stay in business the company was founded
in 2007 by Brian chesky and Joe gibba
and the idea was quite simple they
wanted to rent out air mattresses on
their kitchen floor for extra cash to
people who are visiting in town the
launch was okay but the company quickly
started to run out of money so Brian
chesky took out a credit card then a
second one and another and another
eventually he racked up over thirty
thousand dollars of personal credit card
debt but the company needed more cash so
the founders got resourceful given their
design backgrounds the founders made
collector edition cereal boxes for the
2008 presidential election Obama owes
and Captain McCain's were a huge hit and
the founders sold more than thirty
thousand dollars worth of forty dollar
cereal boxes Airbnb may be a
multi-billion dollar business today but
it's all because the founders were
willing to sell cereal boxes to make it
happen